a Superman anytime you hit a WRA you
could pause for a beat or two or however
many in like this weird
butterf it's kind of cool because the
two tricks are that we learned at the
beginning of the workshop are the 2B
that's like a split same thing and
they're together opposite right which is
actually opposite direction B and they
actually transition into each other it
doesn't happen in normal pois spitting
think it doesn't it doesn't cool right
anyways after doing all that we just did
the grip thing how I put it into one
hand I take it here I flip it put it in
the hand Kate does
the that one you grab it from the
side and
uh Min are pretty much just anytime it's
you know about to line you let it tuck
into your pinky and ring
finger then we did two quick variations
this
thing Eric's variation first which was
to take this you should do it yeah uh
wind up and to kind of hold your hands
you start with the bottom and then
eventually get your whole body going
into it so your elbows are actually
moving you
know kind of like
that the way I was showing it was just
holding it in the place here catching it
back and forth you get better just kind
of tapping it back and forth sticking
the body parts in there kind of
Obviously good at that kind of
concept and then we did the
pter and that pull through can be held
as long as you're keeping it on the
opposite side of your arm that the other
PO on so on that inside you can just
keep that roll going until you want stop
or you can kind of roll through to the
other side and spin out of it I also had
Hindi tell me something I didn't know
earlier was kind of neat that pulling
through there is kind of a way to
transition into meteor normally kind
think that's kind of NE end of
[Music]
the way I like to get into it at first
your first learning is just P the one
that's supposed to bounce do the two
bees and do the two be weave and as it's
coming down to the
leftow we went on to some very to that
um my favorite was turn can add
it m was to turn it around the 3B
Superman which is when it
comes comes around switch from thumb
side doing the spinning part side doing
the spinning part
uh mine was remembering the whole
non-native native side depending on what
arm you hold it with uh not just using
your legs but also using your upper body
cuz it's
identical um and then Crossing between
them and allowing a little bit more
freedom of
motion uh
yeah Fantastic
4 uh we went over Fantastic 4 and how
you learn it which is basically starting
with your Superman and letting your
weave on the inside come and hit your
inner leg the X wrapping uh poy will
then pop over your arm and start leading
the weave and then same will happen back
to the other side essentially what it is
doing is doing like a color switch it's
flipping the entire move upside down and
then flipping it
back and then again taking that to your
upper
body and so on and so
forth and then a
variation oh yeah um just bring it
around your head with fantastic
cor another Point tucks under your arm
I get
it I don't know
so so um yeah thanks guys thanks
everybody
wow Tori is awesome Tori do the behind
the back Superman everybody with the
camera
don't it up
Dar that's got ridiculous
can you show
the Eric would you mind showing your
Fantastic Four
variations
uh
so you have the
four and then you can take move and move
it up pretty much mimicking exactly how
you'd be doing it on uh your lower body
yeah and then you
can do this like cross kind of using
both yeah then you could
do kind of like a
triangle and then the triangle the other
way and then there's the kind
of lazy
and then the six W which
[Music]
is okay so the last one in the six rack
R doesn't actually change direction
right
it no don't know doesn't okay I got it
sweet yeah thanks man no problem